une avocate ce problème d'attractivité
pour les professeurs il existe
réellement
vous parlez de formation tout à l'heure
à ce qu'ils ont les armes finalement
pour pour rencontrer dans ce type
d'établissement escales une formation
préalable adore honnêtement la formation
c'est vraiment l'un des parents pauvres
jeudi l'un parce que la situation ici
face à suffisamment complexe pour ne pas
cibler la en laissant l'autre et les
professeurs de façon générale ne sont
pas suffisamment formés ça fait quelques
années que je suis dans la formation et
au fur et à mesure on a une diminution
du temps de formation et on a eu une
perte vraiment de on va dire d'un des
modules qui me paraissent qui maintient
qui me paraît le plus important quand on
s'adresse à ce genre de public c'est
celui de la psychologie de l'éducation
c'est à dire celui qui permet de
comprendre les publics avec lesquels on
va interagir qui permet d'adapter ses
manières d'enseigner et donc cette
formation ils n'existent plus donc pour
quelles raisons pour des raisons budget
oui enfin je pense je vais laisser à
d'autres mais très très simplement on a
moins d'heures donc forcément et on a
fait des choix qui sont la réforme de la
formation qui interroge beaucoup sur les
deux types de formation mais c'est vrai
qu'on peut se poser la même question
quelle école voulons moore à travers la
formation des enseignants que l'on
propose etc ont discuté la raison on la
connaît une école pour tous à égalité
pour tous soit il ya eu des des moyens
il ya en tout cas des tentatives des
réformes successives pour essayer
d'améliorer les choses mais les
résultats ne sont pas là donc finalement
qu'elle est là quelle est la meilleure
façon d'y arriver
nous nous avons quelques pistes on peut
dire l'élection termes de réflexion
réponse
quand on est à la fois sur le terrain et
puis on a plus aussi de distance
quand on prend le temps de réfléchir à
l'intérieur des laboratoires et
différents labos vont proposer des
choses mais un des points importants qui
ressort et à travers les exemples que
vous avez présenté on peut tout à fait
le pointer c'est qu'il ya un manque de
considération tant des enseignants que
des élèves sa vie des enseignants
on peut parler vous avez parlé de
violence entre élèves effectivement le
cas donc c'est qui qui est oui voilà qui
montre clairement que voilà il a perdu
la vie
en tout cas il ya aussi une violence
institutionnelle il ya une violence
symbolique aussi qui est un problème de
société à la base c'est un problème de
société mais quand on y met l'école même
est une société il faut aussi la voir en
tant que telle est l'idée d'une approche
plus positive en fait de ce qu'on
pourrait faire à travers les savoirs il
approche les autoritaires je lâche le
mot parce que autorités dans la
positivité mais est ce qu'il ne faut pas
un retour peut-être à la rigueur et à
l'ordre alors là je dirais non non c'est
toujours très dur ces mails autorités à
mon avis c'est pas surtout tels que
c'est conçu par contre si on est dans un
processus qui consiste à poser une
autorité à travers les savoir que l'on
cherche à bien partager quand on est
professeur je parle de la baguette sur
le bout des doigts un danger non non je
sais que c'est pas la baguette je
parlais de violence symbolique on peut
se retrouver dans des dépositions
autoritaire non je crois que c'est une
prise en considération complète des
personnes temps des élèves que des
enseignants et il ya je pense un
personnel
il ya aussi une grande importance c'est
le chef d'établissement alors écoles à
l'école primaire la directrice mais
aussi dans le secondaire le chef
d'établissement
je pense que cette angoisse important
des transformations que l'on doit viser